um let's go let's go next
to um let's go to lucas from copenhagen
one of my
favorite cities in the world lucas how
is copenhagen these days
hi can you hear me yes i can wow cool
that's awesome yeah
well um yeah i'm half i'm half german
half danish so um
yeah i'm i'm mixed so i'm um i'm
wondering what your take is on the whole
covet thing here in europe
i mean we're really in this second wave
now and uh whole germany is talking
about like a mini lockdown or like
a yeah wave breaking thing i just want
to know what what your take is on that
and whether you think mine like a
lockdown would be
would be a good choice well listen i i
would i simply defer i it would be
inappropriate for me to say whether i
think a lockdown would be good what
matters is what do the public health
experts in each country say
spain is experiencing this france is
experiencing
this one thing that's important to
remember as we compare what's going on
in the u.s to what's going on in europe
is that uh we are getting to wave three
now i know that
you can say wave one never really ended
in the us because we never got below 20
000 cases a day but the point is we had
dips
and we had a spike at 35 000 to spike at
70 000 and now we're having you know
even 80 000 cases in a day
so any comp direct comparisons
between the us and europe first of all
need to be per capita
but secondly you guys actually
suppressed the second wave
all summer you're only getting the
second wave now
we're already on wave three and so i
think that we should all be careful
to be making any direct comparisons
because you're we're on
we're one wave ahead of you and
hopefully you will never
have a third wave that would be the hope
of of taking measures now
yeah yeah i agree um and i had another
question um
so i had i heard this i saw this video
from uh john stossel i don't know if you
know him
i do know who he is yeah yeah yeah he's
a bit controversial right
yeah and he he had a video where he
talked about like a human challenge
trial
where volunteers would would be injected
with covet
um do you think that's like any uh that
would be an option or you think that
that should be strictly done by
government yeah so this is a big medical
ethics topic which is
if you really want to be sure a vaccine
works or a treatment works you do a
challenge trial which is you
actually rather than waiting around to
see how many people get infected you
actually try to infect them
it's a big medical ethics topic i would
leave it to the public health experts
and medical ethicists it wouldn't i
would have nothing substantive to add
other than to say this is not john
stossel's idea the idea of challenge
trials has been around a really long
time
yeah yeah that's it i mean all right my
friend
great by the way have you ever been to a
place
in uh a copenhagen called fisk bar
this far no no i haven't all right i
recommend the fish and chips there if
you make it
okay cool yeah very good to hear okay
all right thanks so much great to hear
from you
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video